fatality
geek culture wins
[Music]
hi jin han how are you abita is it a
veda yeah yeah okay yeah i got it i got
it yeah yeah
how are you
i will so i before you get started on
shang tsung i know that not many people
know this but you are born and raised in
singapore just like me so what's it like
um transitioning from working on local
tv shows to
mortal kombat
oh there's so many years between that
and motor combat i think
where do you want to start uh i think it
was 25 years ago when i did my last uh
thing in singapore um the tv series
uh
it's it's you know i i am very
uh grateful you know i i
i'm glad that i'm able to continue
doing
uh
what i
did you know started doing like 30 years
ago in theater in singapore and
you know 30 years later i'm still here
and i'm doing uh mortal kombat
have our assassins double their efforts
what of lord raiden if he discovers
we're breaking rules set in stone by the
elder god leave the other gods to me be
that i love you know back in the 90s
uh
i you know it's very surreal you know
but i'm i am grateful you know it's uh
it's it's
it's it's a
very
unusual kind of life
[Music]
well that's lovely is it that you were a
fan of the games when you were younger
uh yeah yeah i was a bit i was a fan of
the movie first i think first and
foremost uh back in 95 and then and then
the games which are the arcade games
basically you know as the machines not
that much the
not pretty much the computer at that
time so i
yeah i mean the movie was so wonderful
it was colorful it was action-packed
great soundtrack and everything and
you know i remember buying the cassette
tape and then playing it over and over
again
and so uh yeah you know i mean it was uh
it was it was if it filled me with a lot
of good memories but then
when i got the the role
you know it is 25 years since the first
movie and a lot of things have happened
to monogamy in that 25 years
there's so many games in between there's
so many uh
you know
other kinds of forms of the movie and
the tv series the website and all that
stuff and and so
um
doing the you know it was important to
do all the research for that before i
took on the role
and there's a lot of research because
the history of it is so large you know i
mean it's about 30 years of history
and
and but it was fun it was fun to do all
that and then
and then come up with a character with
simon mccoy you know that i think uh
you know that i hope that that the fans
will will like
i think just now he was speaking about
how newt's been 30 years and you know
like the lore of mortal kombat is really
deep and wide you feel like shanks on
himself is a his he has a fairly
complicated history he exists in like
multiple different timelines
so how much of the lord do you bring
into your characterization of shangfel
um
quite a bit you know i mean i think
because uh
firstly i mean obviously the two most uh
distinct things about
changsung is his ability to shapeshift
and that comes from his uh soul taking
as well and uh
you know and and that has
allowed him to kind of exist within all
these worlds because he can also
teleport
uh interdimensionally you know uh
with portals and everything so
you know
he fits in very organically with all the
different timelines you know which
diverge and then converge again
you kind of find them in
all these places you know and then
sometimes you don't even know that he's
there because
you know he's shape-shifted and he's
become you know he takes on the
personality of someone else
um so i yeah you know i think uh
uh
i think what we've created is consistent
with uh you know all the lore and the
canon
uh
hopefully we can add one more chapter to
to it
yeah i think we were all leaving the
theaters like my team and i'm just so
excited for like a secret we're hoping
um
but which one of the scenes was your
favorite to film
i have to say the favorite ones were
also not easy because um we
because the place was so
otherworldly right it was so
it was so
uh
exotic and i never seen anything like
that before
and uh it was a scene where we were in
outworld
and we were walking
through this
you know this kind of very this
wasteland
and um that was a place called lee creek
in southern australia and it's out
further out in the desert and we had to
fly in
on these small propeller planes the
place was an abandoned coal mine a
massive abandoned coal mine
and
it was incredibly hot
uh the ground was
cracked uh they had fissures with smoke
coming out and little you know burst of
flames
and we were walking through we had to be
careful though you know they marked out
all the
places where that was happening we had
to walk through that and then it was so
gusty the winds were strong it's
incredibly hot and wearing all that
armor we had to shoot
you know then we had to shoot the scene
um
that was uh
not easy to film but that was also like
one of my most memorable
times because
you know this really was one of those
moments where you stand there and you're
like you can't be you can't believe
you're here you know it feels like an
out-of-body experience just looks like
nothing you've ever seen before
now i know just because you're
mentioning the costume as well like how
long what how long did it take for you
to put on the costume before filming
like literally step into the shoes of
shanghai
no it takes a village to put that on you
know and there's good reason too because
you know the costume is actually made
out of a lot of parts right
uh you can't just have a costume that
goes on like this because
uh
that kind of costume limits mobility you
know and then if you have to move or you
have to fight or anything it's very hard
to move you need to
have a costume that breaks down into
many different parts so you can do it
and so
it was designed that way and there are
many many different parts and many many
different layers
of it um so it takes a very long time to
put on and there is a sequence to put it
on if you put in if you put on i
remember the first few times we did it
you know
if just one hook goes you know
in the
wrong place or goes in in place
earlier than it needs to go the whole
costume can't fit so it needs to put on
in a very
very you know methodical and very you
know kind of a
structured kind of way
that sounds a little bit stressful
oh yeah yeah yeah no and that's before
you even start acting right
now in the movie you got to say like the
iconic catchphrase like your soul is
mine
so what was it like when you found out
you got to perform one of the most
iconic lines in the mortal kombat
franchise oh yes you know you
you think about yeah it means
you think about
the million and one ways you can do it
you know and and then you
kind of
try it and you
you know you you keep doing it until uh
until the director calls action and then
whatever comes out comes out right so
but uh before that you know you're
thinking and you're practicing and
you're you know you're trying it a
million and one ways
you know uh but there's so many lines
like that right i mean i think
for shangsung is not only that line it's
also it has begun
it's finished
so you know you constantly think about
30 years of history
and you know you you you want to make
sure that you kind of
do the 30 years of history uh you know
uh good you know you want to do it well
for that so you think just because we
need to like wrap up an interview i'm so
sad because i have so many questions to
ask you but you know could you do us the
honor of closing this interview by
saying fatality get culture wins not
with the jazz hands but or you're good
if you want to what for fatality
what is it that you wanted to say
fatality is that
italian
geek culture wins oh geek culture wins
okay okay
okay i can do that
fatality
geek culture wins
thank you so much this has been such a
great time thank you ching han thank you
thank you
[Music]
you